i should probably address this public
health experts
are citing certain so-called super
spreader events
as playing an important role in the
spread
of the coronavirus that's right you
probably heard about this a february
biotech conference
in boston has been linked to 20
000 cases and the recent sturgis
motorcycle rally in south dakota
may be linked to as many as 250
000 cases yeah well guess what it turns
out
there have been way more super spreading
events than
we ever knew tons of them events like
the opening of the used kleenex ball pit
in atlanta
yeah in retrospect not a good idea how
about this miami beach's
senior citizen arm wrestling
championship
spoiler alert there were no winners
[Laughter]
a chicago radio station held a how long
can you keep your tongue on an essential
workers face shield competition
yeah yeah it's classic chicago classic
chicago leave it to chicago
the republican national convention's
kissing booth
i don't know what they were thinking now
matt damon i know his heart's in the
right place but matt damon's water
conservation charity
started encouraging people to reuse each
other's
gargle water oh man
and finally san diego's annual phlegm
con they probably should have canceled
it this year
yeah the i was booked but i said no way
good for you andy and andy's a perennial
andy you've gone to flemcon every year
i really have it's great it's gross but
it's great
yeah well i'm glad you sat it out this
year old chum
thank you conan